[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
MICHAEL SIPSER: Let's get
back to space complexity.
So just to review
what we've been doing
from last lecture, which
feels like a long time ago
but it was only two
days ago, we were
looking at those three
theorems, which all
had basically the same proof.
One was about the
ladder problem,
where you're trying to see if
you can get from one string
to another string changing
one symbol at a time.
And all of the strings
were in the language
of some finite automaton, or
you had some reasonable rule
for saying which are the
valid strings, which are not.
And then we built on that idea.
We showed Savitch's
theorem, that
going from any
nondeterministic machine
to a deterministic machine only
squares the amount of space.
And then we finally
proved that TQBF,
this problem about
quantified Boolean formulas,
testing whether they are
true, that that problem is
complete for PSPACE.
So we're going to build
off of that last theorem
today, and talk about one
other complete problem,
and also show a
connection between PSPACE
and testing which side can
win in certain kinds of games.
And then at the end of the
lecture, the second half
of the lecture, we'll
talk about diving deeper
into space complexity.
We're going to talk about a
different part of the parameter
space where instead of
looking at polynomial space,
we're going to talk about
what happens if you have
logarithmic space, which is
another natural point to look
at for space complexity.
But we'll get to
that after the break.
Talk about game
complexity and games--
so when I was little, we used
to play, me and my sisters,
would play a game
called Geography.
I don't know how many
of you have heard it
or maybe it goes under
a different name.
But it was a game basically
about words and places.
And it has a very
simple set of rules.
Let's say there were two people.
You take turns picking
names of places.
And then each person has
to pick a place which
starts with the letter that the
previous person's place ended
with.
So for example, you
have two people playing.
Perhaps you agree on
some starting place
like a major city
nearby, like Boston.
So one player, the first
player, picks Boston.
And then after that,
the next player
has to pick a place that starts
with N, because Boston ends
with N. And so maybe
Nebraska would be
a possible response to Boston.
And then the first
player would have
to respond to that with a
place that starts with an A,
because Nebraska
ends with an A, maybe
Alaska, which also starts
with A, ends with A.
So then Arkansas,
maybe, would be
a reasonable response to that.
And then that ends with
S, so San Francisco,
and then so on, and so on.
And of course, you
want to forbid people
from reusing names because then
you'll just get into a loop.
Saying, "Alaska,"
"Alaska," "Alaska,"
won't make the game
very interesting,
so you have to forbid
that possibility.
Names cannot be reused.
They can be used at most once.
And then, eventually,
one side or the other
is going to run out of
names and not have--
either because of the lack of
their geographical knowledge
or maybe you've just exhausted
all the possibilities--
and will not have
a good response.
And that person will be stuck.
And that person is the loser.
The other person
has won the game.
So the objective is to try
to avoid getting stuck.
So let's just take a look.
I'm going to think about
that game in a slightly more
abstracted, formalized way.
So you write down all of
the legitimate places.
They become nodes of a graph
such as I've shown here.
And then you draw an edge
from one node to another
if that corresponds to a legal
move in the game, a legal step
of the game.
So Boston connects to
places that start with N,
like New York and Nebraska.
So the first person
might pick Boston.
The second person might
pick either of these two,
and then back to
the first person.
If they picked Nebraska,
they could pick Arkansas.
They can pick Alaska, and
so on, just as I described.
Believe it or not, we
actually played this game.
I can remember playing
this game when I was a kid.
That was, of course, before
we had "League of Legends"
and other fun stuff, but
this is what kids used to do.
So anyway, just to get it down
on the slide, the rules are--
assuming we have
two players, we'll
call them Player
I and Player II.
Player I goes first.
And they take turns
picking places
that start with the letter
which ended the previous place,
no repeats allowed.
And the first player stuck
loses, the person who
doesn't have a move to make.
So what we're going
to look at today
is a generalized version
of that, where we're just
going to take away
the names, but just
leave the underlying graph.
And we call it going to call
that "generalized geography."
So here, that can be played
on any directed graph.
You take away the
names of the nodes.
Now you just have
some arbitrary graph.
You're going to designate
a particular node
as the starting node.
And then the players take
turns following those edges.
And because you're going to
forbid having any loops reusing
any nodes, what you end up
doing is, working together,
you're going to be constructing
a simple path in that graph.
Simple path just
follows those edges
and never intersects itself.
And the first player to
be stuck is the loser.
So the other one is the winner.
So we're going to call that
"generalized geography."
And we're going to look at
the computational complexity
of deciding, for a
given graph and starting
point, which side would win if
both players played optimally,
the best possible.
And we'll name that
problem GG, or look
at its associated language.
So here is a graph
and the starting node.
And you want to say that
pair is in the language GG
if the first player, Player I,
who must play at that node A
to start off with
has a forced win
in that generalized geography
game on that graph starting
at A. Again, what I
mean by a forced win--
I'm not going to
define this formally,
though we could do that--
it's not hard to do.
But a forced win is also
called a "winning strategy."
That just means that if
both sides play optimally,
they play the best possible--
not of their capability,
I mean absolutely
the best possible play--
then that Player
I would still win.
There's nothing
that Player II can
do to prevent Player
I from winning
if Player I has a winning
strategy or a forced win.
You may have seen, for example--
there are examples
of this that--
I mean, I don't even
know if they still exist,
but it used to be
in the newspaper.
There used to be
examples of chess boards
and they would start
from a certain position.
And they would say,
"White to win in three."
And so that means
white has a forced win.
No matter what black does, white
is going to end up winning.
But you have to think
of what the strategy is.
It may not be so
obvious to think
through what are the right
moves that white makes.
But the point is that no
matter what black would do,
white would end up winning.
And what you can show--
we're not going to do that--
but for a class of games that
includes this
generalized geography,
either one side or
the other is going
to be guaranteed to
have a forced win.
That's not necessarily true for
all possible games, obviously,
but for a large class of
games, one side or the other
is guaranteed to have a winning
strategy or a forced win.
So let's just review
that, because this
is going to be essential for
the first half of the lecture--
to understand what
we mean by a game
and what we mean by one side or
the other to have a forced win.
And what we're going to show
is that GG is PSPACE complete,
that the problem of
given one of these graphs
and a starting
point, figuring out
does Player I have a forced
win or is it Player II that
has a forced win?
Which side is guaranteed
to win under optimal play?
That's a PSPACE
complete problem.
And so let's do a
little checking on that.
And so I'm going to give
you a very small example
of a generalized geography game.
You have to figure out whether
it's Player I or Player II that
has the forced win, the
winning strategy, or maybe
neither, or both.
Those are the four options.
And you understand Player
I has to play here,
because that's
the starting place
of this generalized
geography game.
So then it's up to
Player II to continue on.
All right, so let's
launch that poll.
You'll have to think
about it a little bit,
and let me know what you think.
Which side has a forced win?
Which player makes
the first move?
It's Player I makes the first
move, and Player I plays,
as I showed you here, this
is Player I playing at A.
So Player I picks A,
and then Player II
has to pick one of these two.
All right, I think we're
the end of the poll.
Everybody's in?
Pick something.
You guys did not do
well on this poll.
At least not too
many of you picked
D. That's a little
reassuring because you
can't have both players
having a forced win.
I did say that in games of this
kind, one side or the other
is going to have a
forced win, so C is not
a very good choice, either.
So maybe you should spend
less time reading your email
and more time listening
to the lecture.
The actual correct answer is B.
Player II, which obviously
is a minority position here--
Player II has the forced win.
Let's understand why.
So Player I plays here.
As I said, that's
the first move.
Player II can either take the
upper node or the lower node.
Player II takes the
upper node, then
Player I has no choice but
to take the right-most node,
and now there's no more
move for Player II.
So Player II will lose if
Player II takes the upper node,
the upper choice there.
Because Player II will go
here, Player I will go there,
and it'll be game over.
And Player I will have won
because Player II was stuck.
However, Player II
had another choice.
Player II could have
also gone down here.
So Player II, if it
played down here,
things are looking a lot
better for Player II.
If Player II goes here, Player
I's move is forced, goes here.
But now, there's another move
left that Player II could make.
So Player II goes here, I goes
there, Player II goes up there.
And now Player I is stuck.
So it's Player II's
choice, Player II
can make a move
which will end up
causing Player I to get
stuck, because that's
the nature of what we mean
by having a winning strategy.
There is some way to guarantee
if you're playing optimally,
and you're certainly
playing optimally,
means you'll take
that lower move.
Then you will take that.
So under optimal play,
Player II will win this game,
and so Player II has
a winning strategy.
It has a forced win.
So I see.
So I'm not going to define
"playing optimally."
There's some questions
here about that.
I'm going to-- I'm going to
leave it somewhat informal,
but we could make
that all precise.
I don't think it
would be clarifying
to go through a precise
definition of that.
We don't even have
to think about it
in terms of optimal play.
You can say that a
player has a forced
win if they have moves
that they could make
in response to every possible
move the opponent could make
that will guarantee that
they will end up winning.
So you don't even have to
talk about optimality here.
Just talk about every
possible opponent.
Every possible opponent
is going to lose
to somebody who has
a winning strategy
and follows that strategy.
I can see there was
some confusion about who
was going first and so on.
I'm glad.
That was part of the reason
I gave this check, just
to hopefully to clear
up some of those points.
So Player I plays here
then Player II goes.
And I got some comments
that some people
were confused about
what does it mean where
does the first person move.
Hopefully, that's clearer.
All right, so let's
move on because we're
going to be spending a
while proving something
about generalized
geography in these graphs.
So let's continue.
So in order to make the
connection between games
and complexity,
we're going to need
to talk about a problem,
one related to one
that we've already seen,
where we can reformulate
that problem as a game.
And that's going to be a problem
on quantified Boolean formulas
called the "Formula Game."
So this is a different game
now, not one that you're
likely to end up playing.
But in a sense in
which you'll see,
this is still a reasonable
game where two players
can play against one another.
And one of them is going to
end up winning and one of them
is going to end up having--
one or the other will
have a winning strategy.
So let's understand
what the game is.
The game is played on a formula.
So you write down a
quantified Boolean formula.
Remember, we talked about
that for several lectures now.
It's a bunch of quanti--
variables with quantifiers.
And then there's a part that
has no quantifiers, which
you can always put into
conjunctive normal form
if you want.
But for the purposes of
this discussion so far,
it doesn't matter.
Later on, we'll actually
want it to be in CNF.
But for now, we just
have some formula.
And associated to
that formula there
is a game, in a
very natural sense.
So first of all, there are
going to be two players.
But now the names
of those players
are going to be Player
Exist and Player For All.
And this is how the game goes--
both players are going to be
picking values for variables.
They're going to say variable x1
is true, variable x2 is false,
variable x3 is false,
variable x4 is true.
And that's how the
moves of the game go.
They're just assigning values
to variables so that in the end,
all of the variables have
been assigned a Boolean value.
And so we end up
with an assignment.
But before we get to
that stage, which players
get to pick which variables?
And the way it works
is the Exist player
is going to assign values
to the Exist variables.
So Exist will pick x1 and
x3 and assign them values.
The For All player is
going to assign values
to the variables that have a
For All quantifier attached.
So in this case,
the For All player
will pick the value
for the x2 variable.
Fading out here.
And the order of
play is according
to the order of the
appearance of the qualifiers
in the formula.
So the way I have it written
out in this particular formula,
it's Exist x1--
so Exist will pick
the value for x1.
Then For All's turn.
For All will pick
the value of x2.
Then it's going to be Exist
picking the value for x3,
and so on, until they get to the
end, and all of the variables
have been assigned to value
by one side or the other.
And now the game is over.
So what's left is to understand
who has won at that point.
And the way we say who has won
is Exist wins if in the end,
this part psi, which is the
part without quantifiers,
ended up being satisfied
by that assignment
that the two players
together ended up picking.
And then For All will win
if that part of the formula
is not satisfied.
So let me just write
that down here.
After the variables have
been assigned values,
we determine the winner.
Exist wins if the assignment
that built cooperatively
together satisfied psi,
and otherwise For All,
if it doesn't satisfy psi.
So think about it this way--
Exist is picking the
values of those variables.
He's trying to make this part
of the formula satisfied,
trying to satisfy this
part of the formula.
For All is picking
values, but she's
trying to make this part
of the formula unsatisfied.
So they're in opposition
to one another.
And in the end, one of them
is going to have succeeded
and the other one
will have failed.
And now, thinking
about it as a game,
depending upon the formula,
one side or the other
is going to have the ability
to dominate the other one
and always win.
And so the question
is, which side
has that ability to always win?
Which side has the
winning strategy?
Of course, it'll depend
upon the formula.
Some formulas, it'll
be the Exist player
who has the winning strategy.
And other formulas, it
will be the For All player
who has the winning strategy.
And computationally, we'd like
to make that determination.
Which side is going to
win for a given formula?
And there's a very, very
nice, and actually very easy
and simple way to understand
that because we've already
run into that problem before.
The problem of determining
which side has a forced win
is exactly the same
thing as determining
whether this quantified
Boolean formula is true
because the Exist player has a
forced win when that formula--
let me say it again--
the Exist player has a forced
win when that formula is true.
So if this quantified Boolean
formula were a true quantified
Boolean formula, then
Exist is guaranteed
to be able to win that game
if it plays its hand right.
If this is a false
formula, the For All player
will always be able to win
if it plays its hand right.
So why is that?
It really follows kind of almost
without doing any work at all.
This proof, even though
it looks superficially
like it might be not
so easy to prove,
it follows for a
very simple reason
because the meaning of what
it means for Exist to have
a winning strategy is exactly
captured by the semantics
of the quantifiers.
Let's see what that means.
What does it mean that
Exist has a forced
win, let's say up here?
That means that Exist has
a move that it could make,
that Exist can pick some value
for x1-- so there was some way
to assign x1 so that no
matter what the opponent does,
no matter what For
All does, there's
going to be a response
that Exist can make,
some assignment to x3, so that
no matter what For All does,
there's going to
be an assignment
to the next variable,
and so on and so on,
so that this thing
ends up being true.
So let me just say
that again somehow.
I didn't feel it
came out very clear.
So Exist has a winning
strategy exactly when
there is some assignment
to x1 that Exist
can make such that no
matter what assignment
that For All makes to x2,
there is some assignment
x3 such that no matter what
assignment that For All
makes to x4 and so on,
makes this thing true.
That's what it means for Exist
to have a winning strategy.
That's exactly what
the quantifiers
are saying in the first place.
So even really without
doing anything,
you can see that "Exist
has a winning strategy"
means exactly the same thing
as the quantified Boolean
formula being true.
So making the test of which
side has a winning strategy
is the same as testing
whether the formula is true.
So let me try to
turn to the chat
before we move on
to anything else.
Here we go.
So I'm getting some questions
about the order of play
and about the alternation
of the quantifiers here.
So the way I'm showing it is
that the quantifiers always
alternate--
Exist, For All, Exist, For All.
That doesn't really matter.
You can have several
Exists in a row,
and that would
correspond to Exist
making several moves
in a row before turning
it over to For All.
But alternatively, we could
just add extra variables which
don't play any role in psi.
And they're just kind
of dummy variables
that serve as spacers so if
you have two Exists in a row
and you don't like
that, you can just add a
For All of some variables that
you never see again in between.
So you can always get it to
be alternating if you want.
OK, also question-- the
difference between phi and psi.
So psi is the part here that
does not have any quantifiers.
So the way we always
write down our QBFs
is they're leading quantifiers
with the variables,
and all variables have to
be within the scope of one
of the quantified variables.
So there are no
free variables that
are unquantified in our QBFs.
And so all of these
QBFs have a run
of quantifiers and then a
part without quantifiers, so
the Boolean logic part.
Psi here is the
Boolean logic part.
And phi is the whole thing
together with the quantifiers.
So I'm not sure I
understand some of these--
why not have the For All
player have a forced win?
The For All player
might have a forced win.
One side or the
other is guaranteed
to have a forced win.
So if Exist does not
have a forced win,
then For All will
have a forced win.
I'm not going to prove that.
That's a fairly simple
proof by induction, which
I'm not going to go through.
Just take it as a fact.
Somebody is asking, why does
For All want to not satisfy
this expression, the psi part?
Well, that's the way
we set up the game.
In order to make this
correspond to TQBF,
just the truth of
this expression,
we want to make Exist
try to satisfy this part
and For All try to make it
not satisfied because that's
what works.
I'm not sure what else, what
other why I can answer there.
I'm going to answer some of
the most basic questions here.
Somebody is asking, how do we
know how many variables to use?
So the variables are the
variables of the formula.
So somebody is going
to hand you a formula.
That's going to have x1 to
x10, whatever that formula has,
some number of variables.
And so that game is
going to have 10 moves.
If the quantifiers alternate,
then the moves will alternate,
but whatever the pattern
of the quantifiers
is going to be the
pattern of the moves.
So Exist is going to follow
the places where the Exist
quantifier occurs,
and For All is
going to follow the places where
the For All quantifier occurs.
So if you have Exist, For
All, Exist, For All, Exist
will move first, then
For All will move,
then Exist will move,
then For All will move.
Together, they're picking values
to their respective variables
with their opposing goals.
Exist is trying to make
the psi part satisfied.
For All is trying to
avoid making it satisfied,
to make the assignment
not satisfy that part.
And if you think about
what that means, just
in terms of the
meaning of that, it's
going to mean exactly
the same thing,
that the formula is true.
So anyway, if you don't--
let's see.
I don't know if there's
any more questions
that I can try to answer here.
It's still about the
numbers of variables.
Each formula is going to
define a different game.
You see the formula.
So the formula, however big--
it may have 50 variables,
it may have two variables.
Well, we'll do an example.
Maybe that'll help.
The next check in, which
is coming up pretty soon--
might actually be now--
we'll give you an example.
So we'll see who is
understanding and who is not.
So let's continue here.
So therefore, the
problem of determining
does Exist have a forced win
is exactly the TQBF problem,
because Exist has a forced win
exactly when the formula is
true.
And what we're going to show is
that TQBF is a polynomial time
reducible to
generalized geography,
but conceptually, we're going to
think about TQBF now as a game
because that's how generalized
geography is set up.
So given a formula
like this, we're
going to construct an instance
of generalized geography.
We're going to construct a
graph where play on that graph
is going to mimic play
in the formula game.
So making the
moves in that graph
are going to correspond
to setting variables
true and false
because the graph is
going to be specially designed
to force that behavior.
So I think we have a
check-in coming in.
Yeah, so let's just see how--
I suggest you pay
attention to this check-in,
really try to think
about it and solve it,
because I think
that'll help you make
the connection between
the truth of the formula
and Exist having a
winning strategy.
So if you take
this formula here--
this is some particular
formula, Exist x for all y,
blah, blah, blah.
There's going to be associated
to that formula, a formula
game where first
Exist moves, assigns
a value for x, and
depending upon that value,
For All is going to move and is
going to assign a value for y.
And after that's
done, this part here
is either going to
be true or false,
is either going to be
satisfied or unsatisfied.
And I want to know,
can Exist always find
a way to guarantee that this
part is going to be satisfied,
or can For All always find a way
to guarantee that this part is
not satisfied?
So you have to look
at this formula
to understand which side is
going to end up succeeding.
So if you're not clear on
the rules, look back here.
Exist is trying to make
this part satisfied.
For All is trying to make
this part unsatisfied.
But they neither of them
has the totally upper hand,
because Exist is picking
one of the variables,
For All is picking
the other variable.
But they're doing it
in a certain order.
First Exist is going to pick,
then For All is going to pick.
So that's the way
the game works--
Exist picks a value, then
For All picks a value,
and then you see who wins.
So who wins?
Who's guaranteed to win?
Can we make sure
that Exists always
wins or can we make sure
that For All always wins
for this particular formula?
So there's just
two variables here.
You can think about this in
either of two ways-- strictly
speaking, purely as a
game, or you can look at,
understand whether that
formula is true or not.
They're equivalent ways
of looking at the problem.
In fact, in a certain
sense, it's the same.
That's what I'm
trying to get across.
Thinking about this as a
game or thinking about it
in terms of quantifiers-- it
doesn't make any difference.
Almost done here.
So all right, last call.
Closing the poll.
I think this one you got.
You did pretty well on.
So the correct answer
is the For All player
has a winning strategy,
has a forced win.
And also, similarly, the
expression, phi is false.
Because if you try to
find some x such that
no matter what y you pick,
this is going to be true,
this is going to be
satisfied, you're out of luck.
Because if you make
x true, well, then--
now I'm confused.
What is going on.
If you make x true,
then x bar is false,
so y bar has to be true.
Now I'm completely confused.
Oh, no.
If you make x true, you
have to work For All y.
So this thing is clearly false.
If you make x true, then this
x bar is going to be false,
and it's not the case that
for every y, setting for y--
because y is forced here. y
is going to have to be true.
y bar is going to
have to be true,
so y is going to
have to be false.
So if you try again
to make x false--
maybe that's one to think about
first-- if you make x false,
you're going to be stuck
on the first clause
because it has to work
for both settings of y.
But maybe thinking about
it as a game is better.
No matter what x
does, y is going
to have a way of making one of
those two clauses unsatisfied.
So if x is true, we can set
y to make the second clause
unsatisfied, and
if x is false, y
can be assigned to make the
first clause unsatisfied.
So anyway, the right answer
is the For All player
has the winning strategy here.
And at the end of the
day, it's not critical
that you understand
this correspondence,
but you have to then,
if you don't quite
understand that,
you're going to have
to take on faith that the
formula game is the same as
TQBF because that's
what we're going to use.
And by the way, I would
like to also mention here
that this correspondence
between games and quantifiers
is something that
mathematicians use all the time.
Because if you have
some expression which
comes up often in
mathematics, where there
are a whole run of quantifiers
in front of some statement,
it's really kind
of hard for anybody
to really get a feeling
for what that means.
If you have six alternating
quantifiers, which
happens often in
mathematics-- you're
going to have statements that
have a lot of alternations
with quantifiers--
very hard to get
a feeling for what that means.
But if you think about it as a
game, it's much more intuitive.
And it's completely equivalent
to think about quantifiers.
Go back and forth between
quantifiers and games.
Anyway, let's look
at the reduction,
the construction that
shows generalized geography
is complete.
A little longer than I thought--
I just want to make sure
everybody is with me on this.
So why don't we call the break
now, and then we'll come back
and we'll look at the
construction after that.
Because the
construction itself is
going to take about 10 minutes
to work through to, figure out
how to reduce TQBF
and build a graph that
simulates the formula.
So I'm going to move
right on to the--
and we'll come back.
So feel free to ask some
questions and get ready for us
diving in to a construction
for the reduction of TQBF
to generalized geography.
So it is an interesting
question about what's
the relationship
between a formula
and when you swap the
order of the quantifiers.
The questioner is asking, does
that somehow relate to negating
the quantifier-free part, the
part without the quantifiers?
And I don't think that that's
the right correspondence.
There actually is
some relationship.
When you say "there
exists for all,"
it's actually a
stronger statement
than saying that "for
all there exists."
And in general, that
actually implies--
exist x for a y implies
for a y there exists an x,
because what you're saying
is that if there exists an x
for a y, there is one x that
works for every one of the y's.
If you're saying for
a y there exists an x,
the choice of that x
can depend on the y.
So there is a
connection, but you
have to think through
what it means in order
to understand that connection.
You won't need to
know that in order
to process what we're
going to be doing,
but maybe it just helps
you think about it.
Other questions here.
I think we're out of time here.
So let's return to our lecture.
So I'm going to go back.
Hopefully that won't
crash everything.
There we go.
So now we're going
to be reducing TQBF
to generalized geography.
Are we all together now?
OK.
So I'm going to illustrate this
construction, which is a very
nice construction, by the way.
I'm going to illustrate
this construction just
by doing an example,
or a partial example,
but I think it'll
give you the idea.
So you understand what
I'm trying to do here,
is I'm starting off with a
quantified Boolean formula.
So here it is.
I'm going to assume it's in
conjunctive normal form, which
I can always convert
it into that form,
maybe by adding some
additional variables,
but without doing anything
too drastic to it.
And so now, starting
from that formula,
I'm going to now build a graph,
where playing the geography
game on that graph-- which
is, remember, taking turns,
picking nodes
which form a path--
is going to correspond to
playing the formula game, which
is picking the variables
of that formula.
And then you want--
if the Exist player
wins in the formula,
then Player I is supposed to
win in the geography game.
So here is how the
graph is going to look.
So try to follow this.
So there's going to
be kind of two parts,
one that's going to
correspond to the variables,
and the other part that's going
to correspond to the clauses.
And so for each
variable, I'm going
to have a diamond
structure here.
So there's a little
starting thing
that's going to be unique
to the first variable.
But then every variable is
going to have a little diamond
structure here.
And they're going to be
attached one to the next.
And we'll understand what this
means when we play geography
on this piece of the
graph, but let's just
understand the structure first.
So this is the start node.
And now, here Player I is going
to play the role of Exist.
Player II is going to
play the role of For All.
And in fact, I'm going
to identify that.
So I'm going to
call-- because it's
going to be helpful just
to think about Player I
as being the Exist player.
So the Exist player is going
to be playing on this graph.
The Exist and the
For All players
are going to be
playing on the graph.
It's really just
Players I and II.
So the Exist player,
Player I, by the rules,
has to pick the start node.
And now it's Player II's move,
the For All player's move.
Now, if you're with
me on this graph,
the For All player's move
is now not very interesting
because it's forced.
It has to go to here,
because again, they're
just picking the nodes of a
simple path in this graph.
So the For All, Player
II, the For All player,
has to go here if Exist
started over there.
Now it's the Exist
player's turn.
And now something
interesting happens.
The Exist player has a choice--
it can either go left or right.
There are two possibilities.
And then after that,
the For All player's
turn, who is,
again, just forced.
So far, For All has not
had much interesting stuff
to do in this, has
not had to think hard.
So no matter whether
Exist went left or right,
the For All player's move is
forced and ends up over here.
And now it's this player's turn.
And again, this is
kind of an easy one.
Oh, before I do that, let's just
look at how that play could go.
So the first two moves, as
kind of I was suggesting,
Exist goes here and
then For All goes there.
I'm going to illustrate possible
plays through this graph
by tracing them out in green.
So now Exist goes here,
For All goes there.
Those were forced.
But now, the Exist player
goes, could either go this way
or could go that way.
So those are two
possible different ways
of playing the game
that we're building.
And now, whose turn is it here?
This was the For All
player picked this one,
so the next turn is the Exist
player, and that's forced.
But now notice-- now
for the first time,
the For All player has to think,
because the For All player
can either go left or right,
so could either go left,
or it could go right.
And so then there's going to
be a sequence of these diamond
structures, where they're
constructed so that alternately
either the Exist
has a choice or the
For All player has a choice,
until you get all the way down
to the bottom.
That is the graph
we've built so far.
Now, if we stopped here, then
whoever ended up at this point,
whether it was Exist or For
All, would be the winner
because there's nowhere
for the opponent to go.
Of course, that wouldn't
be very interesting.
So there's going to be more
stuff we're going to add on,
which are going to
correspond to the clauses.
Now, how to think about
what's happened so far?
Maybe some of you
might be guessing
that when the Exist player
over here has a choice,
could have either gone
left or right, that's going
to correspond-- because this
is supposed to be mimicking
the formula game-- that's going
to correspond to the Exist
player in the formula
picking the variable
either true or false.
So to the left or right is going
to correspond to true or false.
And so let's just
arbitrarily say
left is going to correspond
to picking it true and right
is going to correspond
to picking false.
So the way I've set it
so far is Exist ended up
picking the first
variable false,
then For All picked the
second variable false.
And the nth variable
also got set false.
Everything got set false so far.
Who knows what happened
over here, of course--
so just to understand
what we've done so far.
Now I'm going to show you how
to build the rest of the graph.
So let's take away
the green part.
And now we're just back
to the construction.
The green part is actually
how you use that construction.
So back to the
construction here-- now,
what do we want to achieve?
By the time the players on the
graph have got down to here,
they've effectively made an
assignment to the variables
by going either left or right
at each one of these diamonds.
So the assignment is done.
From the perspective of the
formula game, the game is over,
and now one side or
the other has won.
Here, we want to build
some extra structure here
as a kind of an endgame, to make
sure that the For All player
gets stuck if the
Exist player has
made an assignment
which satisfies
this part of the formula.
And the Exist player should get
stuck if the For All player,
if the assignment that they made
does not satisfy the formula.
So let's see how we're
going to achieve that
with some additional structure.
So there's going to be
some extra node over here.
Let me just tell you what the
structure is, and then we'll
argue why it works.
So going from this
bottom node, we're
going to start the
second part of the graph.
There's going to be
a node which fans out
to a node for each
one of the clauses.
And each one of those
clauses, in turn,
fans out to a node for
each one of its literals.
So you see we have
clause c1, and it
has the literals x1, x2
bar, x3, x1, x2 bar, x3.
So there's a node for each
of the literals in clause c1,
same for clause c2, and so on.
Now we're almost done.
Now I'm going to tell you how to
connect up these literal nodes.
So x1, each node is
going to correspond back
to its own diamond.
So now we're going
to tie it back
to the first part, where
we made the assignment
part of the graph.
x1 is going to connect
back to the true part
of the x1 diamond.
And x2 because, it's
negated, is going
to tie back to the false
part of the x2 diamond
because it's an x2 variable.
Similarly, x1 bar--
because x1 bar--
here's x1 bar in clause 2--
x1 bar is going
to connect up now
to the false side
of the x1 diamond.
And x2 bar is
going to connect up
to the false side of the
x2 diamond, and so on.
I don't have the
other diamonds here,
but the x4 would connect
up to the true side
of the x4 diamond, for example.
That's the whole construction.
Let's understand why it works.
So the endgame here
is we want Exist
to win if the assignment
satisfied all the clauses.
And For All should win if there
was some unsatisfied clauses.
So why does this happen?
So let's put back an
assignment here that was made.
So the one I'm putting
back, the assignment
that they cooperatively
built had x1 being true,
x2 being false, and
some other stuff.
Now, why does this work?
So what we want to
have happen now--
so now, the move
proceeds over to here,
and you need to arrange
it so that Exist
is the one who picks that node.
If this would have been For
All, just add an extra node
to switch whose turn it is.
But you want Exist
to be up here.
And what you want is for For All
to be picking the clause node.
Now, here is the part to
understand what's going on--
we want For All to win
if this is not satisfied.
So For All is going
to make a claim.
If it is not satisfied,
there is some clause
which is not satisfied.
There's some clause
which ended up
being false in the assignment.
So the For All player going
to say, "I think I won.
And I won because clause
number 1 is unsatisfied."
So it's going to pick
clause number one.
So here's the For All
player's [INAUDIBLE]..
Here's Exist player.
And so the For All player picks
the clause claimed unsatisfied.
So over here, For All player
says, clause c1 is unsatisfied.
I'm going to move here.
Exist player says, "Uh-uh,
I don't agree with you.
The assignment, your line--
the assignment actually
makes one of the literals
true in clause c1.
Let's say you made x1 was
true, as in fact, it is here--
x1, in fact, is true.
So Exist is now going to pick
the literal that was true
in the assignment in that
clause, that the For All player
is claiming is unsatisfied.
One of them is
lying at this point.
This is either now true in here,
which means the For All player
did not pick an
unsatisfied clause,
or the Exist player
picked the false literal,
which is the Exist player picked
the false literal so the Exist
player is lying.
Now, the moment of truth
because let's see--
if Exist picked here, now it's
the For All player's turn.
It's connected back to the
true side of the diamond.
So that node was already used.
That's the only place that
For All could possibly go.
For All is stuck,
and Exist has won
the game, which is what you
want because For All's claims
are false and the Exist
was correct in saying
that x1 satisfied clause c1.
So x1 is true, so there's
nowhere for For All to go.
But compare that
with the situation
if the assignment, on
this part of the graph,
had gone through the
false, had assigned x1
to be false, so the path
had gone through the
For All side of the diamond.
Now this node would
still be unoccupied,
would still be available.
So now the For All
play-- so if Exist
was claiming that x1 was
true and it really was false,
the For All player would be
able to move onto that node.
And now it's the
Exist player's turn,
and the Exist would be stuck
because this node down here is
guaranteed to have been used.
So that is the idea.
It's really very beautiful, and
actually not that complicated.
You have to stare at it a bit.
So let's just see what
happens, for example,
if I had one other case-- maybe
it's not necessary at this
point, but if the For All player
claimed it's the second clause
which is unsatisfied in the
mutually selected assignment,
then--
so this is sort of the case
where the For All player
is correct, in that if
the Exist player now says,
well, I think x1 bar
satisfied that second clause,
but this assignment made x1
true, so x1 bar is false.
And so the Exist
player's lying this time.
And so now the For All player
can take this last edge
and go here, and has
one last move to make.
And then the Exist
player's stuck.
So the For All will
win in that case.
So let's turn now,
shifting gears entirely
to a different part
of space complexity.
Instead of looking at polynomial
space, which is very powerful,
we're going to look at log
space, which is comparatively
speaking much, much weaker.
So log space are the things
that you can do when you only
have enough space to
write down, essentially,
a pointer or some fixed number
of pointers into the input.
That's what you get when
you have logarithmic space,
because log space is
enough to write down
an index of something.
So this is what you can do
with a bunch of pointers.
And in order to
make sense of this,
we have to change the
model of computation.
Because if we use the ordinary
one-tape Turing machine, just
scanning across the input,
just reading the input the way
we've defined it,
would cost space n.
And so you can't
even read the input
if you have less than n space
available, like log space.
So we're going to introduce
a different model just
to allow us to define this.
And that's a model
where it's going
to have two tapes, where the
part that contains the input
doesn't count.
And in order to make sure
it's not being cheated,
the input tape is
going to be read only,
but it doesn't count
toward the space used.
Only the work tape, which
now can be written or read,
is going to count
toward the space bound.
So now what we're
going to define is,
using this definition
for our space complexity,
we'll define SPACE
log n, the things
that you can do if you have
only a log amount of space
here, on the work tape.
So the length of the input is n.
The length of the work
tape is order log n.
So we have the deterministic
and nondeterministic associated
classes--
SPACE log n and NSPACE log n.
We're calling it L and NL--
log space and
nondeterministic log space.
And as I said, that's
just enough space
to write down some
pointers into the input.
And let's do some
quick examples.
So if you take the language of
palindromes, essentially, or ww
reverse, that's in log space.
So here is a string.
Here's a string
that's in ww reverse.
And the ordinary
way you might use
to test whether a string is
of this form in ww reverse
might be to cross off
corresponding locations here.
But you can't do that.
It's a read-only input tape.
So you have to somehow avoid
writing on the input tape,
but still testing whether
you're in this language.
It's not hard to do.
You can use the work tape
just to keep track of where
your pointers would be.
And in so doing,
you can just make
sure you're matching off
corresponding locations
with each other in the input.
So log space, because
of its ability
to store some fixed
number of pointers,
gives you enough to test
membership in this language.
So this is in
solvable in log space.
The path problem, which
we've seen before--
you're given a graph, and a
start node, and an ending node,
or a start and a target.
You're given a graph
of an s and t--
it's a directed a graph--
and can I know, can
I get from s to t?
So that problem is solvable
in nondeterministic log space
because the way we would do
that, not writing this down
in any detail,
but what you would
do in your nondeterministic
log space machine--
you have your input graph
written here in the input,
and you're just going to guess
the sequence of nodes one
by one, which takes you from the
start node to the target node.
You're not going to write down
that whole sequence in advance
because that cost you way
too much space to write down.
The only space that
you're going to use
is to remember the current
location where you're sitting.
So you start out, you
write down on the work tape
the start node.
Then you're going to
nondeterministically pick
one of the outgoing
edges from the start node
and look at its associated node,
and replace that on your work
tape, and keep repeating that.
If you ever get to the node
t, then you can accept.
And you also have to
be a little careful--
I don't have this on the slide.
You also have to make sure that
if the graph has a loop in it,
because that's not allowed
in space complexity,
so you're going to need
also a counter to make sure
that if you count up to--
you've gone through
a number of nodes
which exceeds the total
number of nodes in the graph,
then you can shut down that
branch of the nondeterministic,
because it's just
going in a loop.
If there's any path
that connects s to t,
there's certainly
going to be a path that
has the most of the number
of nodes of the graph in it.
So path is in NL.
This language here
is in L. What's
the relationship
between L and NL?
Well, certainly the
deterministic class
is contained in the
nondeterministic class.
That's all that's known.
Whether these two collapse down
to be the same is unsolved.
And so we're going to spend
a little time next lecture
exploring this.
But let's first look at some
of the basic facts about log
space, sort of setting
ourselves up for next lecture.
So first of all,
anything that you
can do in log space you
can do in polynomial time--
in a sense kind of
trivially, and in a sense
we almost kind of really
proved this already.
Because if you remember,
we said that anything
that you can do in a
certain amount of space
you can do in time that's
exponential in the amount
of space, in the
corresponding amount of space.
So going from space to time
blows you up exponentially.
And the exponential of
order log n is polynomial.
So the way we're
going to prove this--
and again, we kind of
proved this already
but let's just go through it
again, specific to log space.
We'll say-- and this is going
to be a useful definition for us
anyway--
a configuration for M on w.
So we also already talked
about the configuration
of the Turing machine
M, which is just
a snapshot, which is the
tape, the state, and the head
position.
When we have an
input, which is sort
of a read-only
input, which is not
being counted
toward the space, we
don't include that
in the configuration.
We just say it's a configuration
of M on that particular input,
but we're going to be
counting configurations.
And I don't want to count all
the different inputs as well.
I'm going to fix
the input and count
all of the configurations
relative to that input.
And so the number of
such configurations
is just simply going to
be the number of states
times the number of head
positions for the two heads
now, times the number of
possible tape contents, which
is, as I mentioned,
here is a number
of different possible
tape contents.
It's d, which is the tape
alphabet, to the order log n.
And that's just going to
be n to the k for some k.
So it's going to be polynomial.
So that tells us that
because the total number
of configurations for
M on w is polynomial,
this machine can only be
running for a polynomial number
of steps.
Otherwise, it'll be looping.
It'll be repeating
a configuration.
And so therefore, that
machine has to run itself
in polynomial time.
So you don't really, in a
sense, have to do any work.
If a machine is
deterministically
deciding a language
in log space,
it's also deterministically
deciding the language
in polynomial time
because that's
all the time you
can use when you
have log space, unless you're
looping, which is not allowed.
So therefore, the
same machine shows
that you're also in P. I'll
get to that in a second.
One thing I forgot to
mention on the previous slide
when I'm talking about
the model is by the way,
this model is not
so unreasonable,
where you have kind
of-- imagine having
a very large, read-only
input and your local storage
is much smaller.
It's much too small to
pull in the entire input.
The way I used to
explain this years ago
was your input as a CD-ROM,
which you guys probably barely
even know what it
is anymore, but you
used to distribute
software that way.
So the ROM was on a
DVD or a CD, which
contained whatever you're trying
to-- like your software you're
trying to distribute.
It was some large
thing, relatively,
and so you imagine having
a smaller amount of memory
relative to that.
So you didn't want
to necessarily copy
that whole thing
into your storage.
Maybe even a better example
now is you think of the input
as being the entire internet.
Obviously, unless
you're Google, you
can't download
the whole internet
into your own local
memory, but you
can have references,
pointers into the input
into different places.
That's perhaps more analogous
to this sort of read-only input
Turing machine model
that I'm describing.
And there's another fact
that I want to mention,
is that anything that you can
do in nondeterministic log
space you can do in
deterministic space,
but now with the squaring.
And that's using the same proof.
That's using Savitch's theorem,
which you have to check also
works down to log space--
same proof.
So anything that you
do nondeterministically
in log n space you can use
deterministically in log
squared n space.
So let me just see if
there's a couple of questions
I want to answer here.
The relationship between L and
NL is not known to be strict.
Nobody knows of an example.
No one knows whether
they're equal.
And have people looked at
sublinear time classes?
Yes, generally when you
have nondeterministic
or probabilistic-- which
we haven't defined yet,
but we will--
people have looked at those
sublinear time classes as well.
Deterministically, it
doesn't make so much sense
because then you can't even
talk about the whole input.
OK, let me move on.
This is my last slide.
Let me see if we can do
this before we break.
Not only is L
contained within P,
but the much
stronger statement is
that NL is contained
within P. And for that
you'll have to do some
work because converting
your nondeterministic
log space machine
to a deterministic machine--
obviously, you're going to
have to change the machine.
And so we'll introduce
a new method here.
Maybe we'll quickly go
over this at the beginning
of the next lecture.
I don't like rushing
through things at the end.
But for this, if I'm given a
nondeterministic machine that
runs in log space, I want
to make a new machine that
runs in polynomial
time deterministically
for the same language.
And I'm going to
define something
called the "configuration
graph" for M on an input w.
And that's just you
take M and w, its input,
and you look at all of the
configurations for M on w--
actually, configuration--
actually, that should be
called the "computation graph."
That's what it's called in
the book, but it's a typo.
Yeah, I'll fix that next time.
It doesn't matter.
Computation graph, configuration
graph, all the same.
Basically, you're going to take
all of the configurations of M
on w, of which we
already observed
are only polynomial in number.
And they become the
nodes of a graph.
And the edges connect
two configurations
if one follows another according
to the rules of the machine.
So here's a picture.
This is some graph.
The nodes of this graph are
the configurations of M on w.
So each node here
corresponds to a snapshot
of the machine, a tape contents,
head position, and state.
So writing down all those
different configurations,
I connect one to
the other, if I can
get to C j from C i in one
step legally on the machine.
And then, the
nondeterministic machine M
accepts w exactly when
there's a path from the start
configuration to an
accept configuration.
Let's assume we have just a
single accept configuration,
as we argued we can do
one or two lectures back,
if we clean up the tapes.
So testing whether you can get
from the start to the accept
is the same as testing whether
the machine accepts its input.
And so because we can
test whether there's
a path in a graph connecting
two nodes in polynomial time,
we can solve this problem on
this computation/configuration
graph in polynomial time.
And so we can figure out whether
the nondeterministic machine
accepts its input.
Sorry, that came a little
faster than I like to do,
so we'll see it again.
So here's the polynomial
time algorithm.
You construct the
graph, you accept
if there's a path from
the start to the accept,
and you reject if there is not.
And so that tells us that not
only is L contained within NL,
but NL itself is also
contained within P.
So here's a kind of a nice
hierarchy of languages.
Not only do we not know
whether L equals NL,
we don't know
whether L equals P.
It's possible that anything
you can do in polynomial time,
you can do deterministically
in log space,
shocking as that
might be, because this
is a pretty weak class.
But we don't know how
to prove that there's
anything different, anything
in P that's not in here.
Last check in.
So we showed that PATH is in NL.
What's the best thing we can do
about the deterministic space
complexity of PATH?
So deterministic.
So this is
nondeterministic log space.
What can we say
deterministically about PATH?
Hint-- this should not be
hard if you think back to what
we've shown very recently.
Get your check in points.
Closing up.
Closing shop here.
All set, 1, 2, 3.
Yeah, so the correct answer
is log squared space,
because this is just
Savitch's theorem.
We can do it in log space
nondeterministically,
so you can do it in log squared
space deterministically.
So this is what we did today.
And as I mentioned,
I will do this again
on Tuesday's lecture,
just to recap that.
All right, so I'll stick around
a little bit for questions.
And someone's asking me
about the nomenclature.
Why is it L and not L space?
Because people don't
usually talk about L time.
So L is sort of--
everybody knows the only
reasonable option is space,
so people just say L and NL.
I mean, some of these names have
a little bit evolved over time.
And even now, some
people talk about--
I call "time classes," some
people call "detime classes."
You can make different
choices there.
Let's see.
Good.
Why does Savitch's
theorem work for log n?
You have to look back
and see what you needed.
And all you needed
to be able to do
was to write down
the configurations.
And if you look back at
how Savitch's film works,
you're just needing to write
down the configuration.
So the deterministic
machine can write down
the configurations for the
nondeterministic machine.
They take exactly the same size.
And then you look
at the recursion.
And the depth of
the recursion is
going to be exponential in the
size of the configurations.
And so you're going to end
up with a squaring again.
You have to go back and
just rethink that proof.
And you'll see nowhere did it
need a linear amount of space.
It works down to--
it actually does not
work for less than log n.
Log n is sort of the
lower threshold there.
And the reason for that
is because you also
need to store the
input location,
and that already
takes log space.
The tape heads-- the
tape heads already kind
have kind of a log
space aspect to them.
And so if you're going to
use less than log space,
then funky things happen
with storing the tape heads.
And so less than
log space usually
turns out not to be
interesting, very
specific to Turing machines
and not general models.
Yeah, so somebody's asking,
suppose in the reduction
to generalized
geography from TQBF,
if the formula had
two Exists in a row,
then you would do kind of the
natural thing in the graph.
Instead of having that spacer
edge between the two diamonds,
you could just have one
diamond connecting directly
to the other diamond
without a spacer edge.
And that would give you
the effect of not switching
whose turn it is.
Somebody is asking me
just a general question,
are people thinking about
these open problems?
I don't know.
People don't say.
There was a lot of work
on problems related,
that seemed to be related to
those many open questions,
like P versus NP, L versus
NL or L versus P and so on,
P versus PSPACE.
We'll talk a little bit
more about some of that.
There's some very
interesting things
that have been developed.
I think there's a sense
within the community
that people are
stuck, and you're
going to need some
sort of major new idea
in order to push
the thing forward.
So I don't know how many people
are still thinking about them.
I hope people are
because I would
like to see the answer at
some point, or get the answer.
I think about them
sometimes myself,
but one has to acknowledge
chances of success
are not high.
So we're a little after past
the end of the hour here.
Unless there's any
other questions,
if I didn't answer your
question, I may have missed it,
so you can ask again.
But otherwise, I'm going to
close this, close the session
here.
OK, bye-bye all.
Have a good weekend.
See you next week.
Take care.